hi everyone my name is jessica and i
work at materialize
i've actually worked at materialize for
a few years now so
i joined as an early engineer in 2019 i
was on the engineering team for
two years i was our strategic
initiatives lead more recently which
means that i talk to you all about
technical partnerships if i've reached
out to you before and i'm currently the
pm for our cloud product
so i'm trying out every job that i can
apparently um but today i'm going to
talk to you about my favorite project
and partnership which is connecting
materialize with dbt
so today i'm really excited to talk to
you all about materialize dbt and
streaming for the modern data stack
so it's the modern data stacks world and
we just live in it i know i feel this
way i don't know if anyone else feels
this way every time i open twitter or
look at a blog post i see another think
piece about what the modern data stack
is and how it's revolutionizing tech
and if you looked at twitter today you
saw that hex apparently created the shoe
of the modern data stack
and it's kind of interesting because i
did not know what the modern data stack
was until like a month ago
and i work in software so i wanted to
start with some definitions for those of
you who might have been in the same boat
as me so
a data stack is just a collection of all
of your data tools so this is
your ingest tools your transformation
tools your reverse etl tools your bi
tools really anything there's probably
12 categories that i've missed here
and the modern data stack is if your
collection of data tools is in the cloud
there are a lot of other things to say
here people have different attributes
that they look at but there seems to be
general consensus that your data stack
is modern if it's comprised of
cloud-based tooling and infrastructure
and that might seem like a sort of
simple transition so what is so good
about the modern data stack
i think it's good because cloud-based
tooling and infrastructure is in general
more powerful and less expensive than
their alternatives
so this means that folks can buy
solutions to hard common infrastructure
problems and this allows this has
allowed a whole new generation of data
products and companies to exist that
wouldn't have otherwise
so this is a trend that started with the
cloud databases in the early 2000s and
we've seen more and more data tools and
data infrastructure tools go this way
since
and
there's a lot to say here and there's
mostly a lot that has already been said
here so i would actually like to focus
on something else in this talk
which is that the modern data stack more
or less exposes a sql interface to its
users
and i think that this is more than a
nice to have
i actually want to take time to detour
here to talk about the fact that
interfaces are important
so interfaces are important when you're
building a product you want to choose
how your user will interact with your
product and you want to choose something
that will let your user try it out
easily
love it and use your tool forever
interfaces are perhaps more important
when you're choosing a product
because you want to choose something
that will be easy for the rest of your
team to use easy for the rest of your
team to understand
so if you wanted to use five data
products and they all had five different
interfaces how would you convince your
team to do that how do you maintain that
how would you explain that to everyone
else in your organization it gets pretty
hard so having a unified interface can
be really important for choosing tools
adding tools to your stack and making it
maintainable
and i wanted to talk a little bit about
the power of interfaces by thinking
about a ledger
so this is a photo of an old french
ledger from etsy it's four dollars if
you're interested um it's from 1906 and
the important thing here is not that
this person had incredibly neat
penmanship although that is pretty
impressive um the important thing to me
here is that folks were doing
calculations in a sheet-based cell-based
way back in 1906. they were doing this
before but this is the picture i found
fast forward to the late 70s and early
1980s and you get a burst of visible
calculators so this started with a
product called fizzy calc which was
followed up by multiplan which was the
original name for excel back in the day
and folks were so excited about these
products that they wrote in the early
1980s
that visi calc was the first program
that was responsible for the sale of
entire personal computing systems at the
time that apple ii
and so they didn't need to reinvent the
wheel to create a really powerful
product here if you squint
really hard
the ledger doesn't look too different
from this excel workbook they're
providing users with a familiar
interface and supercharging what was
powering them
this holds if you take a step further
away from software so on one side we
have henry ford's model t from 1908 and
on the other side we have
the cyber truck from 2019
these cars obviously very different but
the user interface is the same so
steering wheel pedal that makes the car
go pedal that makes the car stop if you
if you could pluck someone from 1908 who
could drive and put them into the cyber
truck today they would probably be able
to make it go uh even if they were
confused about the cracked window
why am i talking so much about
interfaces why did i why you know
doesn't really match the title of this
talk
um
my point here is that i don't think that
the sql interface of the modern data
stack is just a nice to have
i think it's actually been a key to the
modern datasack success so far
but i think it's also caused one of the
biggest problems
and the problem is that the modern data
stack
has been batch based because streaming
systems have yet to expose that same sql
interface that the rest of the tools are
exposing to their users
and i think this has led folks to agree
that batch is good enough so i work at a
streaming database company i talk to
users and folks in the community and
pretty often i hear some version of
batch is good enough and i get it
there's so much tooling around batch
there's so much that's already working
around batch why would you want to
change
i have this tweet from pedram who's here
in the first row he's at hi-touch
and he wrote recently that stream seemed
to me like one of those beautiful and
principal and awful and practiced things
because of how hard it is to get right i
just can't imagine a 30 to 50 person
company with one or two data hires
running off of streams but it's really
easy to do with tables
but the truth is you would be able to do
this if you had a streaming system that
exposed the correct interface to its
users
sql
so
say hello to materialize the streaming
database for the modern data stack
because it exposes the correct interface
to interplay with the rest of your tools
and with the folks at your organizations
sql
so for the most part materialize acts
like the databases you already know and
love you ingest some data you create
views over that data you power your apps
and analytics off of that data but under
the hood materializes it materializes
implementing that interface very
differently
so materialize subscribes to upstream
data sources including kafka postgres s3
kinesis pub hub and local files and we
turn those things into queryable streams
for our users just using sql
and our secret is that under the hood
our database is powered by timely and
differential data flow so timely and
differential data flow are award-winning
battle-tested stream processing
frameworks that came out of
microsoft research and were co-led by
our co-founder and current chief
scientist frank mcsherry
so when you create materialized views
and materialize you're actually creating
these data flows so let's walk through
just at a high level what these
different systems do
so timely data flow is a low latency
cyclic dataflow computational model
introduced in the paper niad a timely
dataflow system
and differential dataflow is a
computational framework built on top of
timely dataflow
intended for efficiently performing
computations on large amounts of data
and maintaining that computation as the
data change
okay do you all got it
because i'm going to quiz you
that's a joke
the problem here is that this is really
hard uh so these are actually
almost literally the first sentences in
each of these projects documentation and
i know that when i joined materialize in
2019 i thought i had made a horrible
terrible horrible mistake because this
is really intimidating
but the good news is that for you as a
user of materialize you don't need to
spend weeks reading rest documentation
or suffering with borrow checker errors
to use the power of timely and
differential data flow because we expose
this power over sql
so you can build correct real-time
applications in analytics just using
sql and materialize
and so how this actually is working
under the hood at a level that is more
approachable and understandable for
folks who don't want to spend weeks
months or years understanding
differential data flow systems
is that materializes superpower is our
incrementally maintained materialized
views
to understand them let's do a quick
uh overview of a traditional
materialized view first
so a traditional materialized view is a
database object that stores the result
of a query
and you might be wondering why you'd
want to do that and the answer is cost
because each time you query your
database you're paying some cost so
that's wall clock time cpu time the
opportunity cost of not running a
different query and cache
and so what these materialized views
will do for you is cache the results of
your common queries it stashes them in a
database object so instead of running
that huge select query that costs you a
bunch of money you run a select query
against that database object which is
relatively cheap so you're effectively
effectively caching your answers and
keeping them fresh
enough and that sounds great but it
comes with a catch
and that catch is that just like any
other cache materialized views will
become stale
as the data underlying that view changes
the result of that view changes so it
means that if you're selecting from a
materialized view you're going to be
reading stale out of date data and to
update that you're going to have to
perform the same expensive query as
before so
using traditional materialized views you
face a trade-off between cost and
freshness
incrementally maintained materialized
views are the same in one way
they're also a database object that
stores the result of a query
but everything else is different so
the result of an incrementally
maintained materialized view changes as
the underlying data changes so they will
update the results each time a new
row arrives and this means that when you
read from an incrementally maintained
materialized view you will always get
correct up-to-date results no refreshes
needed and this might sound to be too
good to be true so let's take a look at
how they work
and i think an intuitive way to
understand how they work
brings us back to our friend the ledger
so let's imagine that we're back in 1906
we're running a shop in france
incrementally maintained views work
today but this is more fun
and now we've before we've been dropped
into this scenario the shop has had
three sales so
one dejean went to marie and went to
pierre and these folks were really big
spenders so we have a total revenue of
16 francs
okay so imagine louise comes in and
makes a purchase for three francs how
would you personally if you are
maintaining this value calculate the new
updated sum okay i'm going to need
audience participation here if you are
going to calculate this sum would you
add
4 plus 7 plus five plus three raise your
hand
we got one
we got two i feel like an auction person
um okay would you add sixteen plus three
that's really good for my next slide
yeah
okay so personally i wouldn't want to
recalculate all the values that i'd
already seen i would look at the fact
that i've already made 16 francs and
just add 3 to that why redo work that
i've already done
instead we'd want to use the arrival of
new data louise's purchase to tell us to
calculate the new sum incrementally
so instead of adding up each shell again
we would only do the minimal work
required so 16 plus three and i'm really
glad you all raised your hand first most
of you raised your hands for the second
one
because this is actually exactly how
incrementally maintained materialized
views work so whether your query is
simple like a sum or whether your query
is
over 10 streams with 30 joins with
different aggregations and limits and
order buys
materialize will only do work as data
changes under your materialized view
which means that you will get up-to-date
fresh results and you are not redoing
any of your previous work
so now that you know about materializes
superpower i'm hoping i hope you're
wondering what you can do with it
um so as i mentioned materialize can
ingest data from a variety of data
sources so
kafka kinesis postgres pubnub
some of these might seem obvious
so cough grand kinesis those are data
streams makes sense that you can query
those as a stream
some of these tend to folks tend to trip
folks up like postgres
so the way that postgres works with
materialize is that we subscribe to
their wall log of their tables so you
tell us what table to track we subscribe
to that table read the wall log and
we're basically doing change data
capture for you so
as you add to tables as you update the
values in your tables as you delete rows
you can interact with that as a
queryable stream in materialize um so
you don't have to set up cdc yourself
which is a pretty big win actually for
most folks
so what you would do here is you would
create a source in materialize so these
are all data sources you create them
with a create source sql statement and
once materialize is
subscribed to your upstream data sources
you can create your incrementally
maintained materialized views using a
create materialized view statement
so materialize is postgres wire
compatible so it looks just like the
create materialized view statements that
you've used in postgres
okay so i have a demo let's see if it
plays
it does okay so this is me in my shell
the other day i'm going to be connecting
to a materialized cloud instance
and here we are talking to materialize
so i'm going to create a source from
pubnub so pubnub is a service they also
provide some free streams of data this
is their market order data so it has
ticker symbols and then it has fake
stock prices flowing through
so i'm creating a source from an
upscreen upstream data source
and it's coming in as just a blob of
text so
i'm going to use a view to cast the
fields in that blob of text into things
that we actually want to use so like bid
prices float order quantity
and then you can see that i've created
that view just a normal view
and from here we want to create our
incrementally maintained materialized
view
so what we're going to do in this demo
is create one that calculates the
average bid price for each
ticker stock symbol
and so the statement here looks like
probably anything you've executed in
postgres or other databases and this is
transforming streaming data in real time
it's actually doing this already
i wanted to show off the columns
so as the data is changing you can see
that the value the average bid value for
each symbol is changing and you notice
that we aren't refreshing these
materialized views we're not prompting
it to recalculate anything
as materialize is ingesting new rows of
data it is doing the work for you on
push
this is just a watch command that's
running that same select in a loop
ta-da
this is materialist thank you
so this is how materialize works this is
our superpower
as i mentioned this is also a simple
example we work for joining streams
across systems for 30 way joins for lots
of data but this kind of gives you an
idea of what a materialized view looks
like
okay so once you've transformed your
streaming data you might be wondering
what can i do with it so you can query
it interactively via psql
via sql via any of your sql tools so as
i mentioned materialize is postgres wire
compatible so we play well with the
postgres ecosystem
actually if you ever find that we don't
work well in the postgres ecosystem
please open a github issue because we
very much respond to those
other ways that you can work with
materialize is to power real-time bi and
analytics so we work with metabase we
work with hex you can make real-time
visualizations with materializing those
tools
and then another one is real-time
applications so we actually have someone
in the audience today
who is using materialized for real-time
applications hi emily
that's emily um she works at drizzly she
is a materialized user and she is using
materialize to power their real-time
abandoned cart emails
so for those of you who aren't familiar
drizzly is an alcohol delivery service
and they found
that folks who put tequila in their cart
today don't really want to buy it
tomorrow at 10 am
so pretty pretty compelling um
so they're using materialize they have a
data infrastructure that goes kafka
materialize kafka and they send out
their abandoned cart emails within 30
minutes um so that was a big deal for
them and it was fun for us as well
but there are lots of things that you
can do with materialize we have
iot use cases finance use cases
e-commerce use cases
and there's lots to talk about there i
would encourage you to come by our booth
or
my office hours
or our community slack to get ideas
about what you can build with
materialize
because for the rest of this talk i want
to talk a little bit more about how you
can build with materialize
and my answer there is using materialize
with dbt
so
you could pretty easily create sources
and materialize views and push data out
to external systems
all by handwriting some sql queries
but there's often a better way to do
that and that's with dbt
so
if you're familiar with dbt you probably
know that until recently dbt only
transformed batch data in batches
so you might be wondering what is
different with streaming data and how
does that actually work in real time
the good news is that almost everything
is the same so if you're using dbt
particularly with a postgres database
you could probably
point it at materialize and it will just
work
because we're postgres wire compatible
which i'm probably going to say five
more times
so the model definitions are exactly the
same materialize speak sql so you just
put your sql in there
you get to use the same dbt command so
dbt run dbt docs dbt test
i put an asterisk there because they
behave a little bit differently but i
actually think y'all will be pleasantly
surprised um and you get the
documentation in lineage that you are
used to
which is great that surprises some folks
that you get the same thing over streams
but we're just sql so it all still works
so what's different
to create the incrementally maintained
materialized view and materialize which
is just our materialized view you just
need to use our custom materialized view
materialization
it's tough to say that so many times in
a row
but
that will create the materialized view
that we just saw in the demo that will
auto update you never need to
update it yourself
and then how some of the dbt commands
are used is a little bit different and
this next one is my favorite slide
especially if you all are using dbt so
hope uh you get to dvt run your models
once and never again
i'm clapping for myself um i think this
is really exciting uh
and this works because if you're
creating an incrementally maintained
materialized view we are doing the work
for you so this is the whole point like
you don't need to refresh your
materialized views anymore you don't
need to push you don't need to schedule
you don't need to check your alerts you
don't need to like make this perfect
little schedule to make sure everything
gets transformed in time you just dbt
run your models once and
never again
i wanted to show that off so i have
another demo
okay so this is building the same
the same thing but with dbt so we're
back in my shell dbt projects look the
exact same because it's just sql so we
have some models
so that's our source
that's our view
and here's our incrementally maintained
materialized view so you see the
materialization type is our custom type
and other than that this is just sql
nothing fancy
nothing special you don't need to know
anything about streams just sql
so that's the same sql that we executed
before
and you can see that we're connected to
my cloud instance
i deleted this after just so if anyone's
worried
that i shared
and
perfect and we can dvt run our models
so we have our source our view
and at the bottom we have our analytics
dot average bid so that's the same thing
that we created by hand but we created
with dbt here
and here's the same watch command that's
selecting from that materialized view
ta-da
it did it again
it does it every time
so this is the same thing but using dbt
and materialize together
so this is a smaller project you might
think it's kind of simple but it gets
handy when you have a lot more views and
then dbt docs also work so
docs generate doc serve
i probably shouldn't have clicked allow
here but i was like stressed
so
um so this is the same docs website that
you see with batch data but with
streaming data and here's our average
bid
i apologize to dbt folks for not
documenting this
but same sql and same lineage graph so
you can get lineage graphs over your
streaming data works just the same
because materialize speaks sql
and dbt test works on streaming data too
so you can run dbt test on your
materialized views to actually catch
data quality issues in real time
this is super fun so this is an idea
that came from josh wills
so quick shout out to josh willis he
actually created the first version of
the dbt materialize adapter so this is
all from him thank you josh
but he came to our hack day a few weeks
ago that we held in collaboration with
red panda and with dbt
and his project was
can i find issues in my data faster with
materialize and dbt so he built this
working project um we actually have a
github repo of a bunch of hack day
working projects that if people are
interested i will share later this is
just a cool one
and so he would purposefully inject bad
data into his streams to see how quickly
he could catch it and he was running
this off a 15-minute cron job and caught
everything because it's it's just sql so
it was just a sequel statement looking
for issues in the stream and he caught
it
he realized after this that you could
actually run this off a tale of
materialize so tail is just like a unix
tail it's just a stream of the changes
so you could actually catch these in
real time and like divert them from
their downstream destinations if you
catch an issue so that probably should
be my next talk
so stay tuned
so we're back to pedram i just
had to highlight him a few times um and
i said earlier that folks have decided
that batch is largely good enough
because streaming systems have haven't
really exposed the correct interface to
fit in to the rest of the modern data
stack yet
and that's why i'm personally really
excited about materialize so i was an
early employee i believed pretty early
in the product i'm excited about how
it's going so far and i feel like
the original set of modern datastack
tools let a new generation of data
products and data companies exist
because they could buy instead of
wasting their time on common hard data
infrastructure problems and i see
materialize today as doing the same
thing
so materialize gives the power of
cutting edge battle tested stream
projects
and it lets people build on top of those
just using sql
so we can bring real-time applications
and analytics to every data team even if
that data team only has a single
developer or a single analytics engineer
because it's all just equal
now if you're like pedram and you
haven't tried it out yet i'd encourage
you to stop by our booth or my office
hours or our community slack to get your
hands on a demo we have some simple ones
available we have some more complex ones
available
and we're more than happy to walk
through your personal use cases and see
where we might fit
i'm pretty confident that we will live
up to the promises that i've made today
and i'm really excited to see what you
all do with
it thank you
[Applause]